[Musique]
c'est ça va pas le faire comme ça ma
petite le cij est ce qu'on pourrait en
fait parce que mettre de la lumière dans
cette salle l'éclairer parce que je vois
personne là c'est voilà ce qu'on
pourrait éclairer cette voie là neuf
voilà ouais j'en perds quelques uns je
vois me lasser déjà bien c'est alors
m'avait pas dit ça mais vous êtes beau
envoyer tout de suite ça fait du bien à
entendre assez ça vous fait sourire et
un sourire c'est merveilleux c'est
magique ça illumine le visage à vous
éclaire un sourire ça rend beau ça vous
rend beau et voilà comme étant de la
lumière ici dans cette salle sur un mot
il y a tout un mécanisme qui vient de se
déclencher à travers ce sourire qui la
réponse naturelle que vous me renvoyez à
ce vous êtes beau un simple engrenage
qui nous entraîne vers l'esthétique
mesdames messieurs bonjour la plasticité
la première idée qui m'est venue c'est
élasticité plasticité élasticité une
même terminaison phonique c'est ce qu'on
appelle une ome haute lte
qu'est ce que c'est que ce mot là alors
je vous ai composé une ome hôtel sous
forme d'épi g en alexandrins avec un
petit instrument de musique
juste pour vous quel sonorités que la
plasticité
on y entend les stries de sa complexité
aux ruelles froissement de la technicité
entre plus la cité excentricités il faut
broyer très lentement la tranquillité la
réduire jusqu'à sol incapacité dénoncé
synthétique duplicité puis soudain
l'aplatir avec férocité à c'est le coup
de grâce à sa perspicacité
alors c'est ans
vous pouvez la ressusciter dans le va et
vient dans le va-et-vient de la
réciprocité comme un accordéon qui
viennent nous réciter sa java champêtre
en toute simplicité et tirer le soufflé
de sa voracité agité l'éventail de sa
véracité de la voilà déployant son
authenticité
nous venons d'exciter son élasticité
faisant démonstration de sa facticité
mais quand l'immensité que la plasticité
[Applaudissements]
le seul intérêt ici c'est la
construction des mots imbriqués les uns
dans les autres qui rend cette plastique
particulière et qui rend le texte beau
pour y contribuer nous pratiquons
d'éloquence fait de figures de
rhétorique provoquant des sensations de
rythmiques ponctuant l'alexandrin de
prosodie qui va diffuser l'expression du
discours nous module on la voit comme
nous mode long la matière car le
plastique est modifiable et souple les
variations vocales sont similaires aux
déformations du plastique des formations
permanentes qui ne casse pas qui se tord
et là jean cocteau écrirait on ne peut
pas traduire un véritable poète nom que
son style soit musical mais la pensée
comporte une véritable plastique et si
la plastique chose la pensée change
cette torsion cette pensée qui change
c'est justement l'élasticité bras
autrement dit l'extension de la
plasticité c'est le mouvement du langage
qui va réduire par le principe d'une
figure de style qu'on appelle la pop up
le mot ordinateur en or die ou
inversement qui valent à rallonge et qui
va rallonger ce mot par le principe de
la drs on va prendre un exemple tout
bête lyon on va le dire en deux syllabes
lions la plasticité c'est l'évolution
des langues à travers l'anglicisme
dubrulle jean et je vois que
beaucoup d'entre vous eh bien vous en
êtes doté par un cette espèce de culotte
en bleu de gênes l'évolution des langues
c'est aussi le chinois et son pénis qui
veut dire assembler les sauts ou la
manière de prononcer définira le sens du
mot le mot est propre à me recevoir une
forme sonore comme une ondulation de
signification c'est l'interprète à sion
le son est adaptable
il se plie il se courbent selon les
circonstances d'émotionnel c'est un peu
comme et là vous allez savoir de quoi je
parle
dans la mécanique des milieux continus
voilà vous savez celle hypothèse
réaliste que les âges les objets se
déforme leur à ce propos il ya un de vos
camarades qui se trouvent ici qui
l'année dernière ma compagne est dans
une de mes promenades noé
je le salue et qu'il a traduit cette
théorie judicieusement ainsi un
élastique c'est un plastique qui n'a pas
su s'arrêter constate au le constatons
le combiné plasticité élasticité du
langage toujours à travers des figures
de rhétorique dans l'amphi biologique
est une manière de s'exprimer offrant un
double sens
alors on va prendre un exemple pratique
est banal il quitte sa femme banale
le jour de son anniversaire
voilà je le répète vous allez comprendre
il quitte sa femme le jour de son
anniversaire c'est ici qu'elle en
philologie dans le sol ici sme celui-ci
jelade or c'est une erreur de langage
qui enfreint les règles de la syntaxe
alors beaucoup d'entre vous d'étudiants
de la tpe
vous n'êtes pas originaire de lyon vous
venez juste faire vos études là et vous
me dit souvent c'est bartosz j'habite
sur lyon je pense aux lyonnais capitan
dessous voilà
la plasticité lastic du mot passe
également par la définition du verbe est
par définition par exemple le verbe
tenir en dénombre plus de 70 moult façon
de l'interpréter de le recevoir et de le
comprendre
c'est par exemple je vous dis vous êtes
curieux au sens bizarre ou curieux au
sens avide de connaissances les
définitions se tordent selon les
situations parfois jusqu'à devenir leur
propre compte leur propre contraire on
appelle ce procédé là les nantis you say
me alors là aussi vous allez comprendre
c'est un peu vous et moi c'est celui qui
invite est l'invité c'est l'autre
l'autre c'est un mot c'est une et l'anti
océni la plasticité ici devient une
gigantesque vitrine dans laquelle nous
trouvons la calligraphie et la
ponctuation pour l'écriture la rime pour
la poésie le rythme pour la chanson la
déclamation pour le texte et alors que
faut-il pour qu'une vitrine soit mise en
valeur question que faut-il pour qu'une
vitrine soit mise en valeur des points
tout simplement de la lumière
fallait-il donc ce chatoiement
d'éclairage pour voir ses sourires
modeler vos visages et apporté un sens à
la plasticité qui illumine la beauté car
la plasticité c'est le visage
le sourire de l'autre sommes-nous
l'observateur ou l'observer
la réflexion ne se fait-elle pas par la
perception alors la plasticité
profondeur
ou superficialité
[Musique]
gaspillage ou frugalité de ventura les
sons
à
le cash est dénudée
lumières clarté à cordonnier du xviie
siècle a écrit les ténèbres ne sont pas
l'absence de lumière mais les froid
causé par l'éclat de la lumière
ne me quitte pas
je ne vais pas pleurer
je ne vais plus parler
le cacherais là bas
c'est me
et à écouter chanter et plus
est ce moi devenu l'ombre de ton
l'ombre de ton
donc
de ton chien
ne me quitte pas
2 me
[Musique]
me kyi
l'ombre de ton ombre l'absence le sombre
l'invisible sourds-muets l'inaccessible
dans cet autre vitrine de la plasticité
il ya le mot le mot qu'on ne dit pas on
le devine il y a le geste et le toucher
c'est le langage des signes
nous avons besoin d'un support que ce
soit par des sons par des matières ou
autres pourvu qu'il fasse naître une
quelconque émotion ce support pour créer
la plasticité sous toutes ses formes
c'est l'idée la plasticité devient alors
réel quand elle produit un sens cette
plasticité peut alors définir ce qui est
beau ce beau profond et pénétrant qui
imprègne l'esthétique un sonore
impalpable et solitaire nous entrons là
dans la caverne de la pensée l'éloquence
silencieuse ressentir tous condé plutôt
que de lâcher des mots dans
l'indifférence d'une vitrine bruyante
vous êtes beau maintenant vous comprenez
le sens véritable de plasticité
nous sommes des prénoms des âges des
métiers des voix des reconnaissances à
nous
est-ce que vous m'autorisez à faire
quelque chose qui est beau pour terminer
justement je voulais vous chanter cette
chanson qui date de loin et je voulais
l'offrir à quelqu'un comme vous qui est
beau ce soir et qui accompagne mon
existence depuis longtemps
valentin cette chanson je te l'offre
pour toujours voilà a failli tromper
souvent oui c'est un peu ma lame est
toujours à feu quand ils se placent ils
sont fluides et jeanne envers un bon
jour du oui de la paire attend
ni soir à la vente ou à môtiers
jamais le sait son arc
se présentent à la canine
ils pleurent et rient en mai jour
les symboles des familiers
ce fait pour être fouillés on le
fabrique du temps
on notera du pays
ça s'appelle comment
parent
dictionnaire marseille
ah bon
un pont
un mot c'est une
celui qu'on ne sait pas
un mot
fait un pays qu'on me le diras par
[Musique]
l'écouté par meetic
dans tous les sens et les parties puis
rêve aussi les mêmes des fag son grand
plaisir c'est quand tu nous as puis à
tes colères
on le suspecte
vulgaire un peu sévère
ils seront plus en plus honnête
ce que vous le préférez sénat
il est si petit gars on va créer comme
injuste
il n'est pas bien que minus
n'hésitez pas à le surprendre
et tendrement le raconte est imaginaire
est le comprendre qu'il reste fixé à
main
un mot
la cab
ah non c'est imminent
celui qu'on ne sait pas
un moment
c'est ainsi qu'on ne le dira pas force
d'en faire un candidat
ils se retrouvent abandonnés
les fragiles n'est pas innocent
il est responsable en sortant la danoise
a des gosses
généreux tous les ans plus
s'il vous fait des confidences
c'est passé ne vont pas mourir
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un mot
dakar 2
c'est m
celui d'auch
je sais pas
un bon
c'est la vie
[Musique]
je vous ai entendu chanter
merci à tous et rester beau
[Applaudissements]